es ist ein riesiger lauschangriff mit
dem außerirdisches leben endlich
dingfest gemacht werden soll die privat
finanzierte us-initiative breakthrough
listen hat in den letzten jahren unsere
galaxie abgehört und jetzt insgesamt 2
petabyte an daten veröffentlicht aber
jetzt kann also jede und jeder mit nach
hinweisen auf außerirdische
kommunikation suchen und wenn es signale
gibt stehen die chancen nicht schlecht
sie zu finden
pixum science fiction gibt es spannende
science videos abonnieren kann und
activity glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
computer werden immer schneller
effektiver und so steigen von jahr zu
jahr die chancen aus den daten von
radioteleskopen außerirdische signale
herauszufiltern
jetzt gibt es einen riesigen datensatz
der bei der suche nach außerirdischen
vielleicht den durchbruch bringen könnte
denn so viele daten gab es noch nie es
handelt sich um insgesamt 2 peter bei
dem daten von radioteleskopen die die
initiative break so listen nun ins
internet gestellt hat dafür haben
radioteleskope drei jahre lang die
milchstraße nach möglichen funksignalen
abgehört die von außerirdischen
zivilisationen stammen könnten
das untersuchte funk spektrum liegt
zwischen 1 und 12 gigahertz und die
rohdaten sind noch längst nicht alle von
fachleuten analysiert wurden zu
berichten es wissenschaftler innen von
der universität kalifornien in berkeley
auf der jahrestagung der amerikanischen
gesellschaft zur förderung der
wissenschaften aaas bei der erfassung
der ganzen daten war das optische
teleskop dieser universität mit der
bezeichnung automatik planet feinde
beteiligt und außerdem auch das wien
bank observatorium in west virginia
hierbei handelt es sich um die größte
lenkbarer radio schüssel der welt die
hälfte der gesammelten daten aber stammt
vom australischen parkes radioteleskop
das mit einem antennen durchmesser von
64 metern als das größte bewegliche
teleskop dieser art gilt die gesamten
daten sind nun im internet zu finden und
somit können sich ab jetzt alle bei der
suche nach hinweisen auf außerirdische
kommunikation beteiligen denn klar ist
das ganze ist ein riesiger berg an
arbeit die hoffnung ruht darauf dass
sich andere fachleute anschließen und
bei der suche helfen aber auch ganz
normale leute
hier und ich können sich beteiligen auf
einen teil der daten kann über das
bürger forschungsnetzwerk city toom der
universität kalifornien zugegriffen
werden die entsprechende analyse kann
auch von zu hause erfolgen dazu der
israelisch russische unternehmer juri
milner der die private search for
extraterrestrial jones kurz die
initiative unter anderem zusammen mit
dem astrophysiker stephen hawking
initiiert hatte seit menschengedenken
war die suche nach leben jenseits der
erde mit limitierten datenmengen und
front irrt wir konnten bislang also
immer nur spekulieren
jetzt erhalten wir immer mehr und mehr
daten und wir können damit wirkliche
wissenschaft betreiben indem wir all
diese daten auch der öffentlichkeit
zugänglich machen kann sich jeder der
möchte an der suche nach antworten auf
die große frage beteiligen
schon im vergangenen sommer 2009 10
hatte die initiative erste daten
veröffentlicht seitdem hat sich die
gewonnene datenmenge allerdings
verdoppelt und die fachleute sind
weiterhin optimistisch da zu ende simeon
von der university of california in
berkeley
das galaktische zentrum ist die
energetisch wohl ungewöhnlichste region
in unserer heimat galaxie und liegt im
fokus aller an unserer sieht die
initiative beteiligten einrichtungen und
instrumente
sollte es dort eine fortgeschrittene
zivilisation geben so könnte diese
vielleicht die energie der
supermassereichen schwarzen loch im
zentrum der milchstraße anzapfen um so
mittels starker signale auf sich und
ihre existenz aufmerksam zu machen doch
es bleibt nicht nur bei der
veröffentlichung der gigantischen
datenmenge erste analysen haben die
fachleute gleich mit veröffentlicht die
wissenschaftler innen haben dazu radio
emissionen von 20 sonnenstern genauer
ins visier genommen diese sterne sind so
gelegen dass außerirdische
zivilisationen die passage der erde von
der sonne beobachten könnten dh die
vorstand haben quasi die perspektive
umgedreht und angenommen außerirdische
zivilisation suchen genauso wie wir nach
anderen außerirdischen zivilisationen
dazu die us-wissenschaftlerin sophia
scheidt die ebenfalls an dem projekt
beteiligt war
wenn andere zivilisationen teleskope wie
wir haben dann würden sie aufgrund
dieser transits wissen dass die sonne
planeten hat und auch
dass es auf der erde leben gibt wenn sie
wissen dass wir hier sind dann könnten
sie uns signale schicken bisher hat es
aber noch keine gezielte suche danach in
dieser himmels regierung gegeben noch
wurden also keine eldeen signale
aufgespürt wie die bisherige analyse der
radio emission der 20 nahe gelegenen
sterne zeigt doch klar ist wie gesagt
eben auch dass bislang nur ein kleiner
bruchteil der daten ausgewertet wurde
das große ziel der fachleute ist es alle
daten mehrmals zu analysieren um nicht
zu übersehen zudem soll die ganze suche
noch ausgeweitet werden auch die
radioteleskope des very large array in
den usa sollen demnächst bei der
fahndung nach außerirdischen signal mit
am start sein dazu werden spezielle
module installiert dazu der forscher
news eemian dieses interface wird es uns
erlauben eine leistungsstarke weit
gefächerte sieht die durch muss form
durchzuführen die weit vollständiger ist
als alle bisherigen suchen diese art der
große vorteil hier kann bei normalem
betrieb der teleskope quasi mitgehört
werden zudem ist das system in der lage
auch ergänzender analysen der daten
durchzuführen und es sind ja schon
signale entdeckt worden über die immer
wieder gerätselt wird fast railbirds
außerirdische signal entdeckt anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren cooler kanal auf youtube
es lohnt sich auf jeden fall denke ich
mal also bis dann bleibt dran